hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play Octodad
now we were dumped off in a tank after
going on a ship meeting our wife for the
first time before we anger Hulot made
two babies don't know how still working
on that the science isn't for huh huh oh
no it's a shark is that a bad thing I
seem to have a look of steely
determination ordinarily like when I'm
not in the ocean I seem to be kind of a
floaty douche but now I seem to be like
a stone ville that's gonna give me what
how was I supposed to do I was doing as
fast as I could I think wait a minute oh
well hang on and wait let me okay
oh I get it oh I was supposed to hold it
down a lot longer and get like a rhythm
going with maximum thrust and not do it
so quickly okay I got it now
I'm all about it I am a octopus do I
keep calling myself a squid I think I do
I don't mean to I still catching up what
am I supposed to do it's still catching
up yeah no no no mister shucks no I'm
gonna get away I'm a stone-cold badass
you can't see this look of game face on
me you can't get none of this are we oh
we're re-enacting a whole bunch of
scenes from Finding Nemo Zout house is
gonna be eat that shark yeah yeah baby
I'm coming for you my lovely lady lumps
no not quite like that
it's a shark on forever or what is that
it is it over okay whoa not what I meant
to do dude
No let's get crushed
oh all right hey now you're crying now
you're horrific crying oh no that's just
a squeaky of the thingy yep
damn ever to put a Naboo and I'll play
Hannibal
gotta get the hoosh before I get the
bouche you know what I'm here
not this one oh okay Oh shouldn't dying
be a considerable concern of mine I
won't the other way I really wanted to
go the other way I don't exactly have
steering here guys it's kind of just oh
oh okay this is why I want to go the
other way you dick we're gonna get me I
am the best
look at my I'm gonna get to my family
thank you if those porpoises help me
were those they did Oh dolphins help
humans when they're attacked by sharks
did you know oh thank you so much you're
the bet don't they also eat octopi I'm
pretty sure what is that said a beluga
whale see that's a beluga whale I'm not
mistaken I'm not up to power on my
nautical animal expertise you're helping
me get out Oh
what well I thought you were helping me
get out you just try to get fed by the
people outside what a selfish douche
forget all the things that what I'm back
here now how did this help me in any way
okay oh it is nice have you
father why almost closing time where
could he be
no no I saw him go in a weird or another
mystery
yeah well wait as long as we can
yeah our little kid how you doing
excuse me ma'am is judging I have bad
news about your husband oh don't trust
him have we met
wait yeah I've seen you a good old
friend of my husband's what can you tell
me about him everything no not my family
now my family you bastard oh I can't
face I told you it's a game face uh was
that sent me was that my leg that I
ripped off after I filled it with semen
Oh gotta get to the kibble with my okay
ah how good it is to be back on two legs
and holding this pipe can I not yeah
goddamn fish on look what my crab game
face saw my head and then get this to
ready to go to bed then I'm gonna go get
down oh it's not a head thing never mind
going straight perfectly not normal
anymore totally badass
100% I look so weird and squiggly ah
come on
that's okay I don't need it cuz I'm
perfectly badass the way I am damn it I
wanted to go down this way anyway
perfectly normal anybody oh I see how
that screaming sea slug must be in here
somewhere right
what you need is a little bit of a
distraction oh what's that over there
yeah master she like no way no how let
me just put on this Cup crown disguise
oh yeah no one will be able to take me
now just grabbing it
dude yeah hey buddy nice ass Wow oh my
go huh no limo okay
perfectly normal alright so what am I
supposed to do now I need to get out of
here what is right last time a jellyfish
couldn't raise a human okay yeah that's
completely ridiculous I need to figure
out a way to get okay I'm trapped
underneath it that's good too I like
this I like this okay all right yeah
you're you're not a hundred percent sure
you saw some the only 99.9999% what I
supposed to do oh okay where am i oh no
okay
I gotta get this screen door and take it
with me Sudha Lee stealthy difficult
yeah this place since the incident
I swear yeah I answered yeah yes Kate
yeah yeah yeah you keep talking you
dicks I got this on lockdown right here
no don't roll that way don't roll that
way you [ __ ] yeah go through the lost
and found
no no me I do my could using watch no no
no normal hmm Dyer save yourself
so normal oh all right there's a thumb
thing over there ooh I all ladies rooms
have such nice I was aren't right off
the wall over there
wait over here we have more important
work to do time to get this showdown on
the road [ __ ] yes figure out how to
stab dancing for two seconds man nothing
makes me lose my voice more than Octodad
I swear that's much better
Boosh you hear something coming from the
break room no it's probably just joe
yeah joe sound an alarm why in the world
would I need to sound an alarm uh okay
Boosh this is not a good idea
turn it off thank you
Oh Oh I know what I need to do
oh so I need to I need to do some I know
what I need to do take this toaster no
not that no that's a banana this I'm
gonna put it in here
you are our your earner warden uh yay oh
that poor poor it's been yeah make sure
he's all right no no what am I supposed
to do
why was that a good idea where was this
a good idea yeah yeah yeah and there we
go you shoot okay Neil I call that get
in there
I'm so angry I am so angry I get in
school
okay all right that camera flip I swear
- Aisha I was gonna kill myself okay now
if I could just figure out a way get
outta here
there we go you come on yeah there we go
well that was easy why there we go okay
seriously no game makes me lose my voice
more than Octodad cuz god damn it you
[ __ ] just bought thank you thank you I
gotta excuse me it affects things cuz
you're breaking him he makes this huge
mess then splits hey give Joe a break he
probably had to get home to his wife and
yeah exactly
that's exactly what I needed to do and
that's exactly what I'm gonna do
okay all right then all right then you
bastard oh come on how do you expect me
to do this this is absolutely ridiculous
e this is completely unequivocally bull
right here this all this all this bow
baloney how in the effing eff do they
expect me to do this I guess if I climb
up that ladder but they're right there
ain't doing this no yeah okay that's can
you not put your arm there move your arm
thank you oh I know is he still looking
oh he's still look at me well fine ah
yeah like a lovely ballerina OOP oh
what's the matter Bob someone well if
you see dragon you know attaboy attaboy
get at it tre get my leg up relatively
high put it down leg or the leg a leg
lower low that leg lower that leg
yeah here we go hit me I'll take that
eat with me so tre our turn if you know
what I mean it's like the tables are
turned but I only have Trey
no no no oh I see how this is it he was
a little boss hmm
does it make any sense how would he even
walk on land
yeah he just knows I'm not crazy
yeah you seem crazy clearly I guess you
don't know anything after all yeah why
did you let him tie up your son it's not
leaving until you understand oh okay you
see he is uncle fools I'm not crazy
right yes because you're right doesn't
mean you're not coming looks just like I
had sex with an octopus you have them be
called octopus but I still caught you
down no oh very good
Oh Riedel don't post coming up oh no I'm
out here baby
I'm good at this oh wow oh no no no okay
still alive it's okay my kids are only
slightly dying that fact was I supposed
to do ahh
get away from me oh no no no no no no no
no I was supposed grab the flashlight
yep yeah yeah ah how do I do this how do
I do this oh okay that's how I do it
okay
oh boy this is gonna be bad yeah okay
I'm okay Wow
good job kid okay that's good
come on come on come on yep no no no no
no no no oh well yeah buddy
okay no no no no no not now not now not
now no no I love the dramatic music
going on in the back knee [ __ ] okay this
is gonna be very far let's try other
foot first this time okay yeah I know
shut up lady
yeah let's dance a little bit and I
reach no ah straddle it with my powerful
groin yep okay yep blind in the blind ow
he machetes me in the face meat cleavers
me okay alright okay
yeah yep yep yep yep
I got a kid oh I got it look at my game
face I got a serious case game face
going on here hey I got us
Oh yep there we go
yep
good job daughter of mine
what okay plug what why would I need to
do that oh that was not good okay what
Oh what am I just dead okay there you go
oh I am down whoa what why am i down yup
yup yup yup
oh dear oh dear oh dear how am I
supposed to get those things down from
there what am I supposed to plug them
with maybe a little bit of this I don't
know you're I gonna try whoa that was a
close one
no oh okay I got it I got it I got it I
got it
what the pow okay I I just shrugged that
one off my voice is seriously gone guys
by now
no [ __ ] not that that can I go over here
now shove it on there shove it on there
I didn't get what happened there but
whatever get it get it get it come on
there we go yeah yeah yeah buddy no no
no buddy
yeah yeah yeah buddy no no no yeah yeah
yeah hold on to it where are you going
where the [ __ ] got you piece of [ __ ] you
son of a [ __ ] you're gonna die in
flames got it didn't know okay I just
I'm gonna set this down so that I can
get this and move it and then subtly do
this okay yeah okay that was good I
guess what do I do now is this my chance
to execute the chef this is my chance
hello hi hi hi oh he's happening oh I'm
winning him over with the power of oh oh
you really forgive me even for the wall
girl oh your family really loves you oh
I not bother you again
Oh
I can't tell what nationality you're
from but oh man honey hmm
so this news will take some getting used
to
yeah but I was imagining much worse
Playboy but next time tell me ten years
earlier okay second that is yeah where
did me a live-action wasn't interesting
John yeah all right yep bye mr. chef man
oh yeah all right so that's the end of
it obviously my voice is almost
completely gone but hopefully it'll come
back quickly this whole series has been
a serious exercise on my voice just
because so much of me just yelling and
frustration but other than that I really
love this game it was seriously fun this
episode ran a lot longer than I thought
it was gonna but it wasn't enough to
break it into two I could see but
seriously this game was awesome I loved
every minute of it even though most
frustrating moments of it because it
gave you guys a whole lot of laughs and
I'm have to say this might be my best
series I've ever done and I'm happy to
say that you know I put a lot of heart
and soul into playing in the editing of
it so I apologize and my voice is just
not very uh soothing at the moment but
uh hang on let me tone it down a bit man
turning up the turning up the volume in
my microphone so that I can I don't have
to yell or I don't have to talk loudly
or clearly but okay this is a little
better luck so my about my voice is
strong it bounces back pretty quickly
but just thank you guys so much for
being here with me thank you guys so
much for watching with me and
subscribing if you're new to my channel
and you saw this I know that a lot of
people are coming in through this series
and I really do appreciate it I do you
know mostly horror stuff but there
hasn't been as much more stuff as late
but I always love doing these fun
creative games you know just games that
have imagination and soul to it I mean
I'm a I'm a say things heated in the
moment where you know I'm frustrated and
I'll say I hate it but in reality I
couldn't love things like this more and
with me coming up on 1.5 million
subscribers I'm so happy to say that I'm
getting better at doing these and I'm
I'm getting better at giving these games
the the respect that they deserve it and
I'm so happy to you know to see things
like this come out of the gaming
community like this is a very
independent project so you know it's
really cool to see this all happen so
just thank you everyone who made this
game possible thank you guys everyone
for watching thank you for the new
subscribers coming to my channel there's
a lot more stuff to come if I find cool
games like this I'm definitely gonna
play but playing this every day was
really hard in my voice as you could
tell but I'll be back in no time
oh also some sharp-eyed people may have
noticed I got new glasses um these are
my old glasses if you didn't know people
don't have ears straight out in front of
their face so this didn't work anymore
so but I like these so I know a lot of
people were freaking out so anyway this
is a really cool experience so thank you
guys so much for watching thank you
young horses if you haven't bought it I
would I really recommend it it's got a
co-op mode I don't know if I'm gonna do
anything from it but you know just it's
got a lot of fun features and there's a
lot of work Steam Workshop stuff that
you can do and hang it wait a tick where
am I going now with my lovely family
ladies all anyway there you have it
that's the end of it everything burning
down in flames but that was amazing
thank you guys again I'm getting out of
here hope you have a great day and
thanks for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
but I really do want